M it's
God it's
God Muslim I just I just reverted to
like um like two months ago you
converted to Islam two months ago
yeah what uh what made you
convert um it's just that I have some
you know some doubt
yes some out about the Bible and that's
yeah that's why well what made you
convert to Islam what convinced you that
Islam is true well in Islam it's really
easy to you know to understand on this
say that God is one and God sent a
prophet and the last prophet is Muhammad
and that's all you know is really
understanding so but in Christianity um
you know I don't really understand about
the Trinity and like that like so it's
kind of like you know
confusing no are you are you not really
a
[Music]
Muslim I am a
Muslim let me hear you say
sh yeah sure yeah sure yeah yeah of
course
yeah that was
tough no read that was
tough that's so what that that wasn't
that I mean that was close but it wasn't
the shahada bro it
was cl I'll take it I'll take it let me
let me ask you this what is what are
your thoughts on Muhammad's marriage
relation well well well do you you know
that's why um um like that's not what I
come from here I
just want to let you know that why I
don't worship worship Jesus that's what
I'm asking you you you rejected you deny
worshiping Jesus to follow to follow
Muhammad who had a certain relationship
with AA as a new Muslim I want to know
what you think about
it well
um well it was you was normal back then
so so it was
okay at the time of Muhammad it was
okay so are you saying that time and
generation determines what's right and
wrong yeah I guess so
do you believe that when the Europeans
and some other people enslaved the
Africans during the transatlantic slave
trade that that was
wrong yeah but it was normal at the
time well I don't
know so even though something can be
normal for a generation or an era
doesn't mean that it's right or okay
right so even if it was normal for grown
men to have relations with little girls
it doesn't mean that it that that that's
okay right doesn't make it
right
yeah yeah okay so ask
again how do you feel about Muhammad's
relationship
with how I feel about um I'll be honest
um it was not right I guess it was not
right I'll be honest but you just
condemned
Muhammad condemned on the on the
marriage of
Asia let me show you
something uh do you believe
that that God would uh ever permit
something like that
God will
permit like would God ever reveal like
this is okay to do to have relations
with little
girls no um no I don't know so like if
there was if there
was if there was someone coming out and
saying that they are a messenger from
God and God is saying that this is okay
to do you would be able to say yeah
that's a false prophet and a false
religion
good so then I want to show you
something
okay I'm not going to show you any H I'm
going to show you the Quran that this is
actually taught in the Quran to have
relations with little
girls and then we'll see if you're
honest enough
to and consistent enough to call this
Rel now for what it
is and but I'll let you be the
[Music]
judge
oh this is chapter 65 verse4 of the
Quran um
sorry so chapter 65
verse4 okay go toal
all right
so this is a chapter about
divorce and those who no longer expect
ministration among your
women if you doubt then their period is
three months so it's talking about when
you divorce when you divorce these
females uh specifically the ones who
don't expect to ministrate anymore they
don't get periods anymore meaning
they're they're too old right menopause
then they have to wait three months
before moving on to the next person it's
to make sure she's not pregnant okay you
got to wait three months all right so
let's just read this again and those who
no longer expect ministration among your
women if you doubt then their period is
three
months and also those who have not
menr and those who are pregnant their
term is until they give birth okay so
the waiting period for the female they
divorcing who's too old to men streate
is three months and the same thing goes
for the the females who have not been
stated what kind of girl is a girl that
hasn't been stated
yet
what well on what is the manist um
have
oh you say what what kind of girl yeah
what kind of female has not you know
minated yet or his
oh it will be like under 12 yeah
underage girls yeah so the
Quran
is showing you that it's permissible in
Islam from the Quran that it's
permissible to marry and even divorce
girls who haven't even hit puberty
yet I
see that's chapter 65 verse4 of the
Quran now to show to show you that this
is in my interpretation I'm going to
show you the scholars let me show you
what the scholars say look The Scholar
this is iir he says the same for the
young who have not reached the years of
ministration their ID or their waiting
period is 3 months like those in
menopause this is the meaning of his
saying and for those who have no courses
meaning the ones who have not
[Music]
administrated this is the Quran
bro well I mean you know as a re um as a
river I I um I haven't read that verse
yet yeah I know you know what I mean um
they didn't tell you this they they
didn't tell you when they was telling
you that the Quran is one and we worship
one God and we believe in all the
prophets and Jesus is a mighty messenger
of Allah but he's not God we only
worship one God beautiful religion you
know we pray we fast they didn't tell
you that we also marry and divorce
little girls or are allowed to do that
at
least oh okay that's um so um like can I
say something real quick
um you know for the people who said that
I am not a Muslim um so here's the
thing of course you're going to find um
in my user you know Orthodox or
Orthodox it was like two months bro I
cannot change that user again I have to
wait like two months to change that
username if you know what I
mean ay I I think you know what I mean
though I don't I don't know if it takes
two months yeah it's said like 30 days I
can't I can't change it yet so if it's
been two months you can change your app
oh I didn't realize that that's
why and and also do you um do you know
the guy um
Abdul no I'm from the YouTube live that
said um that said he said that Allah Li
in good
CA Oh on my YouTube channel yeah yeah
what about it yeah that was me bro I I
am I I am
Muslim that was you yeah that was me
that wasn't you that
BR it was me that wasn't
you I bro I I remember that one yeah you
remember watching it that wasn't you bro
I joined that live I'm telling
you hey hey bro I swear to God uh it was
me I cannot swear on um on God but I
will I will swear BR I swear to um on my
feet like on my
mom it was me no worries so if that was
you uh how could you stay in this
religion
that where that teaches that it's okay
to have relations with little girls when
you said that you would know that that's
a false religion whatever teaches that
well I did know yet but because um I
read the Quran in the beginning but like
I'm not till the end though yeah well
you don't even got to get to the end to
see that it's false yeah yeah I mean
that was um you know as surprising that
I
know what the Islam teaches but so
you're going to still remain in this
religion knowing that it teaches you
know to these
girls I I don't know
man my fure well for me a it would be a
hell no why isn't why isn't it a hell no
for
you I don't know what got into my
brother I know man
I I'll think about it but I don't know
you'll think about it yeah
and and also um what is there to think
abouto I'll just think about it but I
don't know think about
what I'm I'm just confused on the Bible
that said yeah but that that doesn't
mean that you should be staying in a
religion that you know is false just
because you're confused about the Bible
if you
know I mean if
you if you can explain it then that
would be great hold up want to check
something what your Bel is false yeah
same I'm with you if what I believe is f
who gave me this
F oh that's I told you
bro y That's him guys he is a Muslim he
came on the live stream if you uh a
couple weeks ago all right you're
telling the truth good stuff I told you
bro good stuff you're telling the truth
yeah thank you thank you for believing
me thank you all right all right so he
was telling the truth and
uh you know so you're you're here right
now
um so um so do you want me to tell you
why I don't worship I don't worship
Jesus well no I want to know why you're
still a
Muslim well well it's because it um you
know it makes sense like the way they
teachers but well I I um I am a freshman
like um like um you high school in like
high school in the Islam I haven't um I
I haven't read read the read the entire
Quran yet so why join the religion that
you don't know anything
about well I just heard people say
that's why right so you didn't you
didn't know what you were joining you
just you just joined cuz people said
yeah you know people um like when we
like shik and Imam and you know they all
um I'm like they all say it's the same
like they said in Islam they believe in
one God Allah I know know I know the
dollar script I I I said what the dollar
script was I know the dollar script I
know I know what they told you and
so you uh without looking into Islam
yourself without researching and
studying yourself to fact check and um
to confirm what they were saying you
just blindly followed and said yeah I'll
I'll I'll come to Islam not knowing who
Muhammad really is not knowing what the
Quran actually teaches you just went in
like a blind
sheep I don't know bro I'm I'm just
confused
that's so how about this how about you
know to help the conf to it's okay to be
confused and have questions
but to to join something else in the
middle of your
confusion is is out of this world that
doesn't make sense to that doesn't make
sense to me M okay you have confusions
about the Bible or Christianity it
doesn't mean leave it because you have
questions about the Bible and
Christianity you
research and if you research and there's
no you know it comes out that they don't
if there are no answers or no legit
answers then you can make that judgment
and leave I I believe that too but just
because you have doubts or whatever and
then join a religion that teaches
adultery teaches you know relations with
kids teaches you can beat your wife um
and all this kind of stuff that for the
life of me does it makes
sense wait wait you us to beat wait what
you be a wife oh they didn't they didn't
show you that either no I I didn't know
that oh man let me show you that bro
they didn't they
they that's not part of the dollar
script
[Music]
man that's not part of the dollar
script Lord have mercy that ain't part
of the dollar script
y'all let me show you
abibi you can go ahead and we'll prail
if
uh you know
look this is chapter 4 verse 34
broter 4
34 I'm about to pull it up on the
screen you see it chapter 4:34 you see
it on my
screen men are the managers of the
Affairs of women for that God has
Preferred in Bounty one of them over
another
and for that they have expended of their
property righteous women are therefore
obedient guarding the secret for God's
guarding and those watch this now here's
the part
those
who you fear may be
rebellious so it's not that they are
rebellious it's if you think if you
think they might be rebellious against
you they if you think they might be
disobedient toward you this is what you
do you can
admonish banish them to their
couches and what does it
say beat beat them beat
them if they then obey you look not for
any way against them God is all high all
great wow
says if you think that she might be
rebellious against
you if you have any Fe if you fear that
she maybe you see how it says maybe that
she might be rebellious against you if
you fear Disobedience from
her you can beat
her
beat oh oh yeah I know
that so you you joined a religion that
promotes wife
beating child relations and also adult
Tre and other kinds of sick
behaviors is this a religion of God bro
will God tell you now these supposed to
be the words of God will God tell you
husbands to beat your wives will God
tell you
this no it's only um I think it's that
Satan would do it that's what Satan do
exactly would God tell you that you
could marry and divorce little girls
before puberty or is that what Satan
would tell you to
do yes
San so
then you have joined a religion of Satan
and not of God
bro and it's as clear as day
oh let me just show you some more things
about Muhammad man this is who you're
following I didn't know you know I I
haven't read the Quran that far you know
yet I know it's okay but look at this
this is sahkari 3175 s bukari is the
most authentic Hadith book that they
have it's second in Authority Under the
Quran all right so when it comes to
their authoritative books you got the
Quran obviously number one and then you
got s bukari is next so this is what it
says this is what Aisha said herself the
child bride this is what Aisha says once
the prophet was
Bewitched so that he began to imagine
that he had done a thing which in fact
he had not
done how in the world can you follow or
believe in a man that was Bewitched at
some point how can you trust anything
that comes out of his mouth when his own
wife even says that he was
Bewitched
bech Bewitched means means under demonic
or or dark magic under the powers of
Satan okay I get it y some so someone
cast a spell on him or whatever and
controlled his
mind
okay wow
that's do you believe that a prophet of
God can be
Bewitched prophet of God
bewitch um
um no no you can't the Bible says that
the spirit of God is what guides the
prophets there's no way that a a demonic
Spirit can overtake the spirit of God a
demonic Spirit can't come over the
prophets but this is who you're
following a man who is Bewitched so you
can't trust his Revelation you can't
trust what he's saying
a man who teaches that you can beat your
wife and that you can marry and divorce
little
girls is this is this man from God or
from Satan
bro W yeah for sure man you're right
yeah
same so go ahead and denounce this man
and let's get to to the real truth which
is Christ go ahead denounce Islam
denounce Muhammad there's no way you can
follow this and then let's get to the
biblical
truth um what hold on logic um um before
I um like I said it um I don't know I
don't know if you heard about this but I
have you know some question about um you
know the
Quran you have some questions about the
Quran um it said when um like when it
said um
when they say I mean they say that um
you know they killed Jesus but um but
they on alive him not it was made appear
appear to them so I was like wait what
wait hold on so they so like they on
alive a
messiah I thought I thought the Jews
don't believe in the
Messiah yeah they don't believe that
Jesus is the Messiah so
no about that verse yeah I'm telling you
yeah right here no Jew would brag about
unal living the Messi the Messiah no Jew
would brag about
that so even this this entire picture
this entire story here is an absolute F
fabrication it's false and
silly yeah that verse you know that
verse Mak me confused I was like I
thought Jewish don't believe that you
know Jesus is the messiah
yeah they
didn't um but they said they on the live
you know
Jesus I was like confused I don't know
man yeah just just it's false that's
what it is it's just simply
false that's I asked that question to um
an Imam um they they gave me um a
different answer but man it's crazy
yeah and not NE neither of them do they
have answers when they give answers it's
either they are making stuff up and
doesn't line with the text they're just
lying to you or simply they don't even
even
know you know but fact of the matter is
bro all of this is just false all of
this is false it's just to to mislead
people away from the gospel away from
Christ
bro that's yeah that's I I was like you
know surprising L
that that's for so man yep really what
we do man we show the truth if you're
sincere bro if you're sincere and you're
really a Muslim if you're sincere you
know
uh you know then that's good only God
knows your heart you know what I'm
saying uh only God knows your heart you
know hopefully you're not playing any
games or anything like that you know
that your soul is your soul it ain't
mine so it's it's not up to me what you
do with your with your
knowledge but uh my only job is to show
you the truth and you do what you
want
so even you admitted that this religion
is from
Satan learn about Christ The True
Religion yeah
sure all right go ahead man go ahead and
denounce this man denounce this as
satanic bro
man I I you know I I renounce in my
heart
good what's your question about the
Bible what's your question about Jesus
uh
yeah I don't really remember the verse
or the chapter but I'm sure it's in in
the New Testament I'm sure it's in the
New Testament where Jesus said um you
know um like he say he said something
about your God and my God yeah
John yeah that verse yeah that verse is
the reason why I don't worship Jesus
because of that verse he said your God
and my God so Jesus have a God I was
like so he's not
God okay well let's break this
down I just had the Bott
open there it is let's write this down
okay John chapter 20
so you know that the Book of John starts
off by identifying that Jesus is God
correct oh
yeah so in the Book of John you have
throughout that Jesus is God so this is
what we're going to establish we're
going to
establish who Jesus is in the Book of
John
before the 20th chapter and then get to
the 20th chapter and
see whether or not it's a problem with
Jesus is saying that fair no yeah okay
so
obviously we have John 1 verse1 and 14
that says that in the beginning was the
word the word was with God the father
and the Word was
God he was in in the beginning with God
all things were made through him and not
anything and without him nothing was
made that was made so everything that
has ever come into existence came into
existence through the word who is also
God understand so
far then it says in verse
14 the word became flesh and dwelt
amongst us and we beheld his glory as
the only Son of God the Father full of
grace and truth so the son or the word
of God who is God and created all things
who's one in essence with the father but
is distinct from the
father decided to come on and uh take on
flesh so we see that Jesus right in the
very first chapter is identified as God
who created all things
right you sure you with me yes it don't
just let let me know if it's like yeah
no no that that a right you know be
honest with let me yeah okay yeah for
sure so Jesus Is God from the very first
chapter then we get down to verse
18 talking about the father it says no
one has seen God at any time but the
only unique God who is at his side at
the father's side he has made him
known so even Jesus is called God the
unique God in verse 18 of John 1 he's
literally called God monogan Theos the
unique God the only God who is at the
father's
side he makes the father
known okay boom so you have two persons
father and the son who are both
identified as God not that they're two
different gods but they're both
identified as having the same divine
nature the same Divine
Essence so that's chapter one it's
already established so then when we get
to John
20 how is it then that Jesus can
say that I I am going to my father and
your father to my God and to your God
how does that make sense if Jesus Is God
how can he then say that he's going to
his
God how does that make sense well it's
simple in Jeremiah 32:27 it says God is
the God of All Flesh you with me uhhuh
God is the God of All
Flesh there's
no uh no you know there's no uh what's
it called like right It's All Flesh
there's no left no flesh left out he's
the God of All Flesh in John 1 what did
it say happen to the word it says that
the word became flesh and dwelt amongst
us so if God is the God of All
Flesh when the word who is Jesus Takes
on
flesh at that point when he takes on
human flesh that's when the father
becomes his God in that way that he
submits to the father's
Authority that make
sense yeah yeah so this is why he can
say I'm going to my father your father
my God and your God because once Jesus
Took on flesh that's when the father
became his God pertaining to his
flesh it's not that father is a
completely different Divine being than
Jesus it's that because they share that
same divine nature
it's just that the father has Authority
and and uh you know he he has Authority
and his God over Jesus pertaining to his
flesh because he's the God of All Flesh
doesn't mean that he himself is not God
either this if we continue watch let's
we're in John chapter
20 let's continue we'll drop down that
was that was verse 17 we're going to
read verse
28 or 27 it says then Jesus said to
Thomas put your finger here and see my
hands and put your put out your hand and
place it in my side do not disbelieve
but
believe and look what Thomas says to
Jesus Thomas answered him and said my
Lord and my
God Jesus said to him now watch how
Jesus responds after Thomas just called
him his Lord and God watch whates Jesus
responds he doesn't say no don't call me
that no stop stop I'm I'm going to your
God no no I'm not your god stop he
doesn't do that he
says you believe because you've seen me
blessed are those who believe without
sin wow so Jesus affirmed that he is God
and
Lord ah okay makes sense this is why we
have the trinity bro the Trinity you
have God and His Divine infinite Essence
consists of three persons the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit and what you see
here is when the son being the word
takes on flesh humbles himself takes on
the form of a servant meaning as human
and as
flesh as a servant of the Father the
father is his God in that way he's the
God of All Flesh but it doesn't mean
that he lost his own Divinity he he
still also shares that same divine
nature with with the father Jesus when
you're talking about Jesus you're
talking about the Divine person who has
two Natures he has the divine nature and
he has the human nature the flesh nature
oh so he have both of the
nature so that's why Jesus can be God
Lord of all of us while at the same time
also saying that the father is his God
in subservience to him
oh it's like um
so it's like a father and son right like
um let's say you know father we call our
dead a father because we respect him you
know what I mean and like we respect him
and we we honor him but here's the thing
you cannot you cannot disobey your
father your
god oh no no I mean our God I mean in
the flesh you cannot do that because you
know the Bible said of course like that
and and also the Quran said all of that
um um but here's the thing so we're all
human a different is that my father is
my father my father is um a greater than
me um um we still human like
that yes your father is greater than you
when it comes to I guess Authority right
but you're you're still equal with your
father because you guys both have the
you're both human you have the same
nature the same substance yeah both both
human but we have a we have a different
U what you call it um like um a
mentality
something a different what a different
mentality different person you can say
yeah yeah yeah personality I yeah you
guys are you guys are different I mean
when it comes to humans you're you know
although you guys have the same human
nature like you guys you're both humans
you're not the same human as him right
you're not the same human being as him
but you're a different human being than
him and a different person yes yeah
makes sense but so but with Jesus here's
here's the difference so with Jesus he
and the father are the same Divine being
that the same Divine being yet they're
different persons the same Divine being
different persons
you know and we are not like God where
um where we are like there's multiple
human beings in human persons right
there's only one Divine being there's
only one Divine being God that's how
that he's different than us and within
his Divine being within his Essence
consists of three persons instead of
just
one yep Father Son and Holy
Spirit okay yeah makes sense
yeah when when you're reading the Bible
bro you got
to uh you got to look when you're
looking at a verse like like what we did
with John chapter 20 right you're in
John chapter 20 but it
negated the 19 chapters that came before
chapter 20 that sets up what you are
going to see in chapter 20 you know so
the the Divinity of
Christ from John chapter 1 all the way
up to John chapter 20 is already
established so by the time you get to
chapter 20 you already know Jesus is God
who came flesh and is a humble
servant so when Jesus in chapter 20 says
things like I'm going to my God and your
God it won't surprise you in light of
the first 19 chapters
says also like when he said your God and
my God so um in my opinion I think when
he said that one is because of his human
nature
exactly you got it
bro human nature and God nature he have
both but when he said that words he uses
his human nature no so it's not that the
human nature is speaking he himself the
person is speaking like the natures
don't do anything like Natures don't
speak they just are you know uh but so
because he has two Natures when he when
he says my God that is it's pertaining
to his human nature so when he when he
speaks it's not that his human nature
speaks or his divine nature no Jesus is
the person who is speaking but when he
speaks you can tell by which nature I
guess is highlighted by the words that
he says oh yeah yeah oh okay when he
said my God so
only oh okay I think I get it yeah only
human says by God it highlights his
human nature it highlights it's not that
his human nature is speaking but it
highlights his Humanity oh it's like
it's like you know only
um only a human can say that you know
what I
mean if a go said if a God say she have
a god it doesn't make sense right yeah
in his own if he doesn't have if he
doesn't have a created nature like a
human nature yeah it doesn't make sense
for him to say that okay if God said he
he have a god it doesn't make sense but
when a human said he have a god it makes
sense oh okay okay that's what yeah
so
um uh I forgot what I wanted to touch on
I just wanted to clarify something but
but yeah I'll just elaborate on this
it's that Jesus because he has a divine
nature and a human
nature um like so for example before
Jesus Took on a human nature because he
did that at a point in time before he
did that the father was not his God they
were this they you know they that that
that Dynamic didn't happen because he
wasn't he didn't take on
flesh right he didn't take on so that
Dynamic wasn't there yet it is only when
Jesus Took on flesh that that Dynamic
happened where he humbles himself takes
on the form of a servant in flesh and
therefore now he can say that he has a
god which is the
father because he has a human
nature a right Mak sense makes sense
the deity of Christ man it's all
throughout it's all throughout the
scripture bro like yeah and also and
also it makes sense that God you know if
God is all powerful and all all known I
mean I mean like I asked myself um you
know can he can he become can can can he
become a man if you want to
MH yes of course he can of course he can
and see that's that's nothing to him
yeah that's nothing oh okay it makes
sense now yeah that's sure that's
nothing to him so this is this is the
Jesus that you left right
for Muhammad who you just found out who
he really
was who says that he's the judge of the
Earth the Messiah Divine Son of God who
came for our sins take on God's Wrath
for us so that we wouldn't have to so
that whoever proclaims the name of
Christ and submits to him is saved and
washed
clean saved and watched clean of their
sins this is who you left you didn't
know him yet
oh I felt AB I'll be honest with you you
know because like a lot of a lot of
Muslims you know in your life um like in
the past month that I've joined in your
life um you know a lot of Muslim or
maybe some of the Muslims like they
don't being honest I was like what bro
what is this guy doing you know what I
mean bro it is true it's not true not
true not true yes yes or no that's it
you know what I mean yeah as a hey bro
I'm telling you as a Muslim I I you know
I have doubted some of the Muslims that
don't be
honest so hey bro I'll be honest with
you hey man that's yeah that makes sense
what your man absolutely bro this is the
Christ that we have man this is the Lord
that we have his scripture is clear we
don't have to lie or beat around the
bush and when our when we doubt we have
answers like we we can doubt and God
through his grace and his Mercy guides
us to to know him to you know he invites
us to reason with him I said this before
to another Muslim
like this is the god that we serve a God
that's not afraid of the doubts or your
questions but he invites the questions
he invites you to express your doubts to
lay it before him so that he can give
you
rest I don't know man like you know for
some reason I don't know
like I felt guilty I don't know yeah
that's and what what that is is uh it's
con it's called conviction
yeah I I don't know the holy spirit is
convicting you bro the holy spirit is
convicting you for rejecting the Eternal
Son of God who gave his life for you for
going to a satanic religion that thank
God you have renounced in your heart but
it's it's what you did you know you
rejected the Son of God without even
knowing
him and so the holy spirit is convicted
that's the guilt that you
feel come
back man I don't know
um so like there's a verse in the Bible
that said you know this if you said this
you will never be um you will you will
you cannot be forgiven if you do what
you cannot be forgiven forgiven if what
if
you Spirit oh yeah that
one um so you know in my
um I think I think it's like three weeks
ago I say something bad about holy
spirit so I I don't know a blasphemy and
the Holy Spirit it's not just speaking
about bad about the holy spirit it's
it's reject because it's the Holy Spirit
who regenerates your hearts it's it's
the holy spirit is the one who makes us
alive spiritually again he's the one who
makes us alive in Christ so I if you're
rejecting the Holy Spirit if you reject
him and refuse him then you are bling
the holy spirit because it's the Holy
Spirit who who who regenerates
you no the Holy Spirit can take an
insult but you rebelling and rejecting
him you then you're refusing your
regeneration that is why you can't you
won't be forgiven for your sins because
you have nothing to regenerate you so
will I will I ever be forgiven I don't
know man yeah you ask God if you if you
come to Christ confess your sins to
God and from your heart repent to him
tell him that you're sorry tell him that
you believe in his death burial and
resurrection that you trust in him and
him alone for your salvation and you
believe that he is your lord and savior
you are forgiven
oh man yes yeah makes sense as simple as
that
bro
yeah
so you know um like in my past life you
know like before I converted to Islam
like I was a
Christian
but I don't know um you know I get into
you know a lot of um argue about Muslims
like that I've been watching Muslims too
but you know something convincing me so
I I convert it so something convin but
now I realize you
know I felt guilt I don't
know yeah that's the Holy Spirit telling
you to come home man come home and get
to know the true Christ and do it and do
it for real this
time because you know being a Christian
by name means nothing but to be truly
born again and to know Christ that's
something completely different that's
this this time around it will be a
completely different story for you you
won't be just a Christian by name but
you will be a follower of Christ a
Christian in your heart and in your
wall so what happened to the you know to
the people that call themselves a
Christians but don't do what the Bible
tell I'll show you
[Applause]
Matthew chapter 7 starting in verse 21
he says not everyone who says to me Lord
Lord will enter the kingdom of heaven
but the one who does the will of my
father who is in heaven on that day many
will say to me Lord Lord did we not
prophesy in your name and cast out
demons
didn't we do Mighty works in your
name and then I will declare to them I
never knew you depart from me you
workers of lawlessness workers
of so the ones who claim that Christ is
their lord yet disobey him go against
him and their lives do not reflect what
they profess those are hypocrites and
Christ says on that day he will say I
never knew
you you're clear
right
yeah
so that's that's that's what that is
man that's what that is and it's funny
this what it says it says and when Jesus
finished these say the crowds were
astonished at his teaching for he was
teaching them as one who had Authority
and not as their
scribes Jesus came different than anyone
else has ever
come and also yeah I get that one you
know I get the verse Y and also you know
in the Bible or or maybe some people
said it um like a pastor or a priest um
you know this is something about you
know being a Christian it's not going to
be
easy um they said like you will um you
will be sometime um you know like I
don't
know you know they say that um being a
Christian is it's not going to be
easy in this world yeah it is it's tough
man
because this is what it is about in
Christianity you have to deny yourself
that's the hardest thing to do
is to deny yourself Christ says if
you're going to follow me deny
yourself and pick up your
cross you have to walk in this you know
in the self-denial every
day these Temptations these lusts these
these urges these are things that by the
grace of God and power of the Holy
Spirit we have to suppress and put under
submission to God that's hard bro cuz we
we not going to be perfect in doing that
all the time it's tough it's
tough you
know
right so people try to think like oh
Christianity you know it's just you know
rainbows and cotton candy and Skittles
every day no it's
hard it's
hard yeah and also the Bible you know
like something said about um you will be
hated by everyone because of me
yep mother and father Sons and Daughters
cousins nephews and uncles
friends
co-workers they'll hate you for the sake
of Jesus and that is one of the greatest
honors to
have man that's what so bro that's one
of the greatest honors to have Peter
Peter and John when they were persecuted
and thrown in jail and beat they they
returned to the group praising God that
they got to be persecuted in the name of
Jesus for his sake they celebrated and
then everybody else celebrated and
worshiped
God they were excited that that's that
that's a level of boldness and um you
know intimate relationship with Christ
that I I long to have like I aspire to
have that to where even in when my
trouble
my troubles for the sake of Christ I
celebrate I I I see it as an honor to to
go through this for
Jesus
man you know the mus it ain't it ain't
nowhere near what what the what the
apostles going through but Muslims they
dox me they dox my mom and my family put
my address and number out there and you
know weirdos was been calling me and and
stuff like that
you know this type of persecution and
oppression for the sake of
Christ i i i i Relish in the fact that I
am going through this for Christ
I to be a servant to do
this hey um logic I know you know I be a
fans
like like four years
now hey bro you and you U you and Sam um
Sam yeah like I've been watching your
your
videos um like for four years so I and
also I I I really I really want to talk
to you know Sam but I don't know
Sam yeah Sam Sam will have you on Sam
will have you on for sure let him like
post he goes live all the time just post
hit the comment section on his live tell
them where you are and that you want to
have a conversation he'll send you a
Skype Yeah man so what do you say man
you ready to come back home
man um I just have one question like
before you know like um before we we
move on so if if I come back home what
um you know um what what happened to the
friends of mine like you know Muslims
that I've been friend with you preach
the gospel to them that's what you
do you
preach okay that's your assignment your
assignment is to be in these areas and
to make Christ known to all of them
that's your
assignment oh
okay I know that they probably saying
you know you're fake Muslim bro like you
know like that yeah they're going to
tell you that they're going to say
you're a fake Muslim they're going to
say all this kind of stuff honestly I
mean hey you you proved that that you
were telling the truth about being that
same Muslim that was on my my live
stream and uh you
know you're you're telling the truth
about that
um and so yeah I mean you know only God
knows your heart bro only only God knows
your heart um I can only take you for
your word you you know and what what is
in the darkness will be brought to light
if you're lying you know may God bring
it to light if you're telling the truth
I pray that God is convicting you truly
and brings you brings you back it sounds
like you're ready to come back so it's
up to you you
ready you know what you know what
yeah all right I don't have anything to
lose so yeah have nothing to lose
everything to gain
nothing to lose everything to gain so it
has to come from your heart but I can
give you a model you can yeah of course
okay so the Bible says in Romans chap
10:9 it says that if you confess with
your mouth that Jesus is Lord and
believe in your heart that Christ raised
or that God raised him from the dead you
shall be saved so I can give you a model
of what to say oh but it has to come
from your own heart make sense
okay all right so what you can do is so
you can just repeat after me brother um
you say
God God I am a
sinner I'm a sinner I have sinned before
you I've sinned before you and I seek
your
forgiveness and I seek your forgiveness
I believe I believe
that
Jesus that Jesus is your son is your son
who came in the flesh Who Came In the
Flesh to die for my
sins to die for my
sin and I believe that on the third day
and I believe that on third
day he was raised back to life he was
raised back to life for my sins for my
sin and I believe and I believe that you
Jesus that you Jesus are my Lord and
Savior I'm my Lord and Savior amen amen
welcome home
brother welcome
home you was lost now you're found
you
strayed and God brought you
back and you are forgiven you are
forgiven once you rejected the son
joined something you didn't
know and you are forgiven for it it's
done away with you've been buried it's
been buried with Christ and now you
raised alive with Christ by the power of
the holy spirit so this what you do find
a
church find a church get baptized
okay get
baptized make it public Proclaim your
faith proudly and walk in this newness
of
life oh go thank you if you have any
questions brother you know you can just
hit me up um we'll be with you can go
get with Sam you know he'll he'll talk
to you as well if you you know want to
talk to him he can more questions even
better than better than me
you got you got a community of people
that help man we're here for
you I I you know I don't know why uh I
don't know for some
reason um sh I started crying but I
don't know
why yeah it's it's it's the conviction
man that's what happens hey bro I'll be
honest with you I don't know like in the
beginning of the live that I just um
just
join um I don't know it just convinced
me but I don't know man what or how you
know it's the Holy Spirit brother it's
not me at all man it's it's the it's
literally the spirit of God who draws
men to Christ and to the Father the
Bible says that it's only by the holy
spirit that one can be convinced and
confess Jesus as lord it's nothing that
I say it's the Holy Spirit who readies
your heart and your ears to receive the
Gospel and the truth it's not me so this
even the the guilt that you felt that
conviction was coming from the Holy
Spirit the the tears coming from that
comes from the Holy Spirit and then the
joy and the relief that you feel it's
all from the Holy Spirit
brother I can call you brother now
wow so your mission bro get
baptized okay find Church get baptized
find a good Bible believing church
that's preaching the word that's giving
good Doctrine get baptized and
um and be ready to learn and study the
faith so that you can give the gospel to
your friends that you made as a
Muslim man all right that's your mission
bro keep me posted all
right yeah for sure man I appre all
right for sure come I'm back man and and
let's talk some more oh my God logic
[Music]